joining me now three-time nfl defensive
player of the year and one of the
cornerstone players of the houston
texans for the last decade he is the
great jj wadd and it is amazing to me
it's got to be amazing to you jj year
number 10 coming up for you how fast has
that gone by
it's pretty crazy man uh it's it's gone
by fast for sure you know at the
beginning of your career they always
tell you uh it flies by it goes by in
the blink of an eye all the vets tell
you all that and you say yeah yeah yeah
but then you get here and you're ten and
you're like
they everything they said is true it
goes by extremely fast i have two
brothers in the nfl now it's wow
there's some similarities too between
year one and year ten year one there was
no off season program because of the
lockout this year no off-season program
because of the pandemic is there
anything from nine years ago that you
can use to help make this easier when
you go to training camp without the
benefit of the offseason program
yeah so when you think about the two off
seasons obviously neither one had otas
neither one had workouts with the team
um the biggest difference by far is
obviously the chronovirus situation and
what that causes is back in 2011 we
could still train at gyms we could still
get together and the veterans could
teach me the playbook we could run plays
we could do all that stuff
we haven't really been able to do that
this off season because of everything
that's going on so
i'm fortunate i had a situation where i
have a gym i have a field i can do all
my workouts there are some guys who live
in a one-bedroom apartment who the
apartment building shut down the gym
they don't have a field to run on so
there's guys that are in different
situations all throughout the league so
where in 2011 if you weren't training it
was kind of your own fault because you
had access to everything this year it
might be
you're not training because you just
didn't have access to it so i think
that's what we're having to deal with
and trying to figure out this ramp up
period and what it's going to take you
guys ready for the regular season is we
got to first assess what everybody's
been able to do and where their bodies
at because it's much different for every
guy and jj that's a great point too
because in 2011 injuries were up 25
even with the ability to work out in
gyms and work out in groups and work out
on fields this year there's a greater
risk of even
higher injury rates if there isn't that
break-in period that gets guys to where
they would have been if they'd had the
opportunity to work out right and i
think that's the biggest concern from
the players standpoint besides the
obvious health concerns of covet itself
but the injury rate in figuring out
where guys bodies have been have they
been running at full speed have they
been cutting have they been making those
high impact you know moves that you have
to make to play the game of football
which is where a lot of those injuries
come from i mean you look back to 2011
in some of those industries hamstring
pulls achilles tears those are injuries
that happen because you haven't been
able to do what you need to do at that
highest level and so this year with the
circumstances we're at we just want to
make sure guys
aren't put in a compromised situation
purely because we want to start on the
set date
and sports leagues have been trying to
get back onto the field the court the
gridiron etc your wife's league the nwsl
chicago red stars they've been playing
what have you gleaned from her about
their experience playing games in the
pandemic that could maybe be useful when
it's time for you to get to work yeah
it's been a lot it's been interesting
for me to watch because uh she went back
to training you know a month and a half
two months ago whatever it was and they
she was in chicago training and they
were kind of
self quarantining themselves as they
trained to make sure that they can go to
practice every day and get their tests
and things like that and now around utah
in their own bubble um and so they're
basically all in one hotel they're
they're playing all their games at a
facility with no fans and the facilities
cleaned and everything is clean so it's
been really interesting for me to watch
and it's been successful for them so far
they really haven't had any you know
knock on wood they haven't had any
outbreaks or any cases there
and i think they've all been following
it pretty well
not necessarily to the most
enjoyable set of circumstances for him
and she's in a hotel room for you know
18 hours out of the day when she's not
training
but
it is working and so i think it's it's
kind of a give and take on you're going
to have to give up some you know
liberties and things that you're used to
and accustomed to you're not going to be
able to go out freely if you want to
have a season uh like they're having
where they're in a bubble but their
trade-off is you get to play the bubble
concepts been tossed around from time to
time for the nfl i just don't think it
can work there's too many teams too many
players too many coaches too many people
but
the positive side if there is one would
be you know where everybody is i think
one of the practical realities jj for
the nfl yeah a lot of young guys they're
going to want to act like young guys and
they're going to be tempted to go out
and do the things young guys do and all
it takes is one of them bring that virus
into the facility or onto a field and
the nfl has a problem do you have any
any plans any strategies any ideas for
making sure at least your teammates will
do what they're supposed to do just go
home after practice stay there until
it's time to come back at the facility
you know i think that's kind of one
thing that we're all looking at the nba
and the mlb to see how it goes for them
i mean we have an opportunity to where
we don't start for a little while after
they do so we've got an opportunity to
learn and i think obviously we should be
taking that opportunity to look and see
what works for them what doesn't work
for them do guys follow along with every
set of the protocols do the teams follow
along with every side of the protocol
it's going to be very interesting to see
and for us obviously being in our own
cities there is no matter how you slice
it no matter how hard you try to make it
as safe as possible there is going to be
some level of trust factor that's going
to have to come into play where you have
to trust that guys are going to be doing
the right thing on their free time
and that's i don't think that there's
i think it's very unrealistic to think
that it's 100 percent safe i don't think
that's a that's a realistic thing to
think it has to come down to how safe
can you possibly get it and are you
comfortable taking that risk and that's
where you have to have that option where
if you're not comfortable or if you're
in a compromised situation you have to
be able to have that option to not not
be there do you think a lot of guys are
going to do that a lot of guys like do
you have a rough idea of a percentage
that would surprise you uh if if guys
say yeah i just can't do it this year
i'm i'm not i'm not going to be part of
this
i don't i really don't i think that
every guy's situation is different you
know i know some like there could be a
guy who has a child with asthma and he
really just doesn't want to bring it
back home or you have a pregnant wife
and i think that the one thing that i
would say
to that is there shouldn't be a stigma
if you do choose to hop out if there if
there is a legitimate reason for you to
be opting out you don't feel comfortable
whether it's for yourself whether it's
for your family i don't personally think
there should be a stigma with that
because that's you're making the best
decision for yourself and for your
family and
if we ever get to the point where we're
shaming people for dropping out of a
sport
because they want to protect the health
of their family then then we're in a
tough spot
yeah i agree with you on that and i have
a copy of the protocol that's been put
in place between the leading the union
for training camp and everything looks
appropriate six feet apart mass
everything's careful everything is very
deliberate and planned out
but the more i see that the harder it is
to reconcile at some point everybody's
got to get on a football field you're
going to be lined up right across from
somebody as rodney harrison told me last
week breathing and sweating and spitting
and and bleeding and how how do you
reconcile the two
that's what we are trying to do you know
so as players
i've been on these pa calls last you
know we've got calls every three days
now as we get closer trying to figure
all this out and the biggest thing that
we want is just answers to these
questions that we have just like you
have a question there you know how we
want we want answers to the same
questions there's more questions not
just that there's other questions and so
the last thing that we want as players
is for this report date to be set in
stone
and for us to be bumping up against this
report date and then we hastily put
things together just because we want to
make sure that that report date is met i
think the most important thing for us is
getting everything right so that
everybody feels as safe as possible as
comfortable as possible with what we're
going to do whether that is on the
report date whether that's pushed back
whatever it may be but i just don't want
us to get into a situation where we bump
up to this report date and we say oh no
now we got to figure it out that's where
you get yourself in the truck i want to
let you keep on your schedule jj you're
here on behalf of the gatorade beat the
heat program tell us more about that
yeah so like you said at the beginning
of this interview 10 years i've been in
this league and we actually started the
gatorade beat the heat program 10 years
ago when i when i came down here from
wisconsin down to houston it was a
climate shock for me i mean it's 110
degrees there's humidity like crazy down
here so i had to learn how to beat the
heat myself
and one of the biggest things i learned
was that if you weigh yourself before a
workout and you weigh yourself after a
workout out in the heat every every one
pound of body weight that you lose you
have to drink 20 ounces of gatorade to
replenish yourself
so during training camp i mean you could
lose six seven eight pounds depending on
the heat depending on you know pads and
everything
so it's extremely important to get that
electrolytes back in your body and
replenish yourself so you're ready for
the next day and this year more than
ever it's going to be important because
of how hot it is we're training on our
own and now there's going to be many
protocols in place so gatorade's been
good to me and they've always helped me
beat the heat so i'm just trying to pass
on the message i saw a tweet you had
about a month ago about the possibility
of the face shield inside the face mask
all the way down that does not beat the
heat does it i i
my uh second year in the league you know
i i thought it'd be cool i put a visor
on my head i was like it looks so cool i
want to put a visor on i had it on for
about three periods of practice and i
said take this sucker off i'm gonna die
out here i just i literally just the
face one so now you're going to put
something around my mouth and
you can keep that if that if that comes
into play i don't think you're going to
see me out there on the field
well hey jj we wish you all the best we
hope football gets it all figured out i
hope to see you on the field this season
look forward to talking to you again
soon thanks i appreciate it have a good
one take care
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports